team battles in anime are awesome while
it's great to have some one-on-ones and
arguably some of the most memorable
battles in anime history's show the team
battles are no slouches either at its
core the good team battle allows for a
showcase of how two often contrasting
fighters fight together and at its best
the team battle becomes a culmination of
the characters story arcs and
development today we're going through a
list of what i think are the best team
battles in anime doesn't matter if it's
two against one or three against one or
the entire roster against the complete
monster of a final villain i'd hate to
keep you waiting so let's dive in
starting this off is hunter hunter's
crolo vs zeno and silva
hunter hunter has no shortage of team
battles but one thing that really stood
out to me is seeing zeno and silva
battle crollo in the york new city arc
in addition to seeing strong fighters
duke it out i love this fight for how
much it highlights the impact having an
ally can have especially if that's
another powerful ally who can come up
with strategies on the fly krono finds
himself on edge as he's forced to switch
tactics on the go due to the team up and
adds another dimension to the fight that
we don't often see the battle didn't
finish normally as the zoldi acts
abandon their mission but you can truly
see how a team up of two top tier
fighters can push someone as strong as
crolo to the limit despite what the
characters themselves say i think even
sirius chrollo still would find it
difficult to beat the zoldians
[Applause]
coming up is asta and yami versus dante
[Music]
earth your rival being your best partner
in battle let me take that back a bit
okay more than your rival it's your
mentor who's got your back who's your
best partner in battle and this fight is
more than enough proof of that after a
long history of being saved by yami it
feels refreshing to see our star finally
reaching the point of being able to
fight alongside his mentor as equals
even if that means overcoming his limits
to do it it took a while and it's at
this point where we truly see our star
grow up from that noisy annoying kid
early on into a full-fledged badass able
to stand side by side with the big bro
that's been looking out for him since
the start the fight being amazing ends
up becoming second fiddle to the whole
emotional investment thing
why stop at duos when you can have
everyone join the party like ordinal
scale's final boss fight
as a fan of sao i really really
recommend watching ordinal scale even as
a mostly standalone movie it's one of
the best the franchise has to offer and
it has elements that become relevant in
alicization there are many things to
look out for but the highlight must be
the boss fight against an incarnate of
radius a hopeless boss fight against
what's supposed to be einkrant's
original final boss takes the audience
through the emotions of despair and hope
as arsuna arrives and yui brings in
almost every name player from all the
games into the mix everyone gets to get
their shots in and we're treated to some
spectacular movie visuals of arsuna and
kirito landing their signature moves
formally closing by giving us the
satisfaction of seeing einkrad being
cleared it's something that the original
story never got to and it feels
cathartic having this movie give us the
pleasure of seeing it
[Music]
right after that comes another cinematic
tie-in my hero academia the two heroes
i said it before and it still holds true
that my hero academia the two heroes is
a damn good movie an inclusion to the
franchise i just love the movie for the
easily digestible plot the themes it
embodies and this awesome final battle
the final battle which sees the mostly
sidelined all might come through and
give midoriya the hand he needs to
defeat the seemingly invincible wolfram
i get goosebumps when you say run played
as hero and mentor proceed to kick ass
and beat the hell out of the transformed
wolfram one of the best moments that
year in the world of anime and it serves
as yet another one of midoriya's highs a
time he seems to have transcended even
his idol in greatness if you're a fan of
my hero academia in any way come watch
this movie it's worth the time if we're
just this moment alone
and if this list has so far been worth
your time then please consider liking
the video and subscribing to the channel
we're trying to hit a million subs by
the middle of the year and we need a
little bit more help getting to that
finish line whether we make it or not
all depends on you so if you like the
video and you're still not subscribed
then please do so we move on with father
versus everyone
full metal alchemists can't have set up
its final battle any better in a series
with so many explosive powers that ought
to make anyone pop out of their seat the
final battle ends up being a battle of
wills more than anything that's what
makes full metal alchemist such an
awesome shonen despite having all those
cool abilities it's a title that doubles
down on its philosophical themes and
shows in this final battle at this point
father is pretty much god there's just
no way any kind of physical powers would
do him him even mustang's powers
assuming he's even able to fight at this
point would do any good but here we are
seeing father get defeated by the sheer
potential and power of everyone working
together it's symbolic that ed finally
finishes him with the good old fists and
it's so satisfying to see one at the
pinnacle of evolution meet his end
against the scrappy power of human will
there's so much more to fma than this
battle so make sure to start watching
the series
todo and yuji vs hanami is another great
one
while not as climactic as the father
fight todo and yuji's team up against
hanami is one of the best moments in the
entire jujutsu kaizen anime toto has
been the cool bro to yuji throughout
this arc and seeing them put their
quickly built team chemistry in action
in this battle is such a great moment
gojo stole the show at the end but the
teamwork that the two displayed prior to
that is something else don't you think
and that's not even getting to the
amazing animation we got for this whole
fight then again considering how well
the rest of the major fights and key
highlights for jujutsu kaizen have been
animated it's not surprising for some of
you to overlook it after all once gold
becomes less valuable when you've got so
much of it and of course we have to talk
about demon slayer after jujutsu kaizen
i'd say that the adaptation of the red
light district arc passes with flying
colours bringing to life what was one of
the longest battles and arcs the demon
slayer manga had despite lasting for
well over half the season's run the
[ __ ] and guitar fight in demon slayer
never felt that long perhaps it's
because of the magic of how the fight
was structured it's not just a slugfest
featuring the same combatants and with
the main focus being ever shifting it
instead feels like a series of connected
fights you get a bit of dengen versus
the upper moons and then there's the
garmado siblings teaming up in an epic
showdown and the sheer permutation and
gimmicks of the fights makes this long
stretch very immersive face it time just
flew by when watching this fight do i
even have to talk about the animation at
this point though it's demon slayer it's
ufo table you know what to expect
last we forget we move on to another ufo
table production heavens feel
[Music]
ryder and shiro have to be one of the
strangest combinations that worked out
so well nothing about shiro makes me
think that he'd make a good partner for
ryder but seeing how they took it to the
unstoppable saber altar gave me some
second thoughts what i like about this
team up with ryder is how the two of
them strategized and played to their
strengths perhaps it has to do with
shiro knowing his former servants
tendencies but with how they work
together you wouldn't know that they've
pretty much known each other as battle
partners for a while of course the
highlight is more of rider's epic
attacks and how the entire cavern breaks
apart in a clash with saber altar you
can just feel the cataclysmic energy
watching the sequence and this battle
serves to highlight rider's true
strength which is a good thing because
ryder gets jobbed out early on in the
other routes
ending this list is the momoshiki fight
and here's where the all-stars make
their glorious comeback after what
seemed like forever naruto and sasuke
finally returned to fight together in
boruto and it's a moment that will
remember for the ages against a threat
like momoshiki it requires no less than
the finest in the franchise to fight
together once again to take him down no
joke this was probably the most popular
boruto has been in ages and while
nostalgia had something to do with it it
seems that the anime team also went the
extra mile to make this fight super
special at that point in boruto's run
the anime has never looked as good as it
did when this fight was ongoing
bringing out the big guns indeed both in
universe and out of universe i'm sure
you also have some big guns to show so
if you have any other team fights that
you want me to look at tell me in the
comments section in fact if you want to
talk about anything in general just go
ahead comments are good for the
algorithm you might also want to check
out the channel's discord server the
patreon and the instagram links are in
the description i look forward to seeing
you and connecting with you through
those other social media thanks for
watching i hope you have a good day and
i wish to see you again for the next
video
[Music]
you